je sais très fleuri à ça c'est allusion
bah au côté biologique vous savez quoi
dort il adore le jardin les plantes les
fleurs on voit là-bas bleu on voit ça on
voit papillon vert encore
c'est une allégorie de la nature et
c'est un personnage histoire en anglais
l'homme en fer et vous voyez le lion et
la Licorne qui sont les symboles de
l'Anglet alors j'ai vu que sur le vous
savez dans la rue de l'Élysée à côté il
y a l'ambassade de j'ai vu un truc avec
un un espèce de
c'est quoi ça c'est de Charles
c'est ça maintenant vous me dites je
vois bien le je vois beaucoup mieux donc
ça y est ça se prépare avant qu'on
avance dans le dans les préparatifs
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
de doigts petite saucisse saucisse
grosse saucisse alors vous savez à
l'inverse d'un président de la
République je pense qu'il doit
annuellement je pense délivrer un
bulletin médical pour savoir comment il
se porte le roi n'est pas tenu de le
faire donc médicalement c'est pas
exactement ce qu'il y a mais ce sera un
problème de rétention d'eau ou un
problème d'arthrite qui se manifesterait
au niveau des doigts peut-être d'autres
membres du corps que l'on ne voilà pour
lequel je n'ai pas accès dirons-nous
mais voilà ce serait voilà un problème
que toi je ferais bien personnellement
de mettre sa main vous le voyez là c'est
Hugo burno qui est le photographe
dans la poche
il y a plein de souvenirs qui commencent
à jaillir alors on a des mugs déjà on a
des papiers et on a un bouché qui a
lancé et ben une série de 10 ou 6 que
vous pouvez acheter en forme de doigts
donc très bien donc ça maintenant on est
rassuré il fait de l'arabe il fait de la
rétention d'eau une petite arthrite donc
est-ce que on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui
tout est prêt tout est prêt on avance
fortement dans les préparatifs
énormément de détails sont déjà réglés
Benjamin on connaît moult shoes il y a
deux interrogations pour lesquelles on
ne voilà qu'on ne qu'on ne sait pas
encore qu'on ne connaît pas encore
précisément on sait que il a abandonné
la robe traditionnelle la robe à faire
bah oui normalement il devrait porter
des bas de soie avec une jaquette une
livrée là il a dit que non à 74 ans il a
peur de paraître un peu ridicule il sera
en costume civile on ne sait pas encore
s'il choisit l'armée de terre l'armée de
l'air ou l'armée de mer
pour son costume et il y a une autre
petite interrogation il souffre de
problèmes de lombaires
au cheval voilà donc il a fait de
nombreuses et voilà et alors le c'est le
médecin préconise et qu'il partirait du
palais pour rejoindre l'abbaye plutôt en
Rolls-Royce ou en démuller il y a 5
Rolls-Royce ces deux démêler qui sont à
disposition voilà et non pas à bord du
fameux Caro SD coach oui ce fameux
carrosse d'or de celui que je voulais
piquer tu n'as aucun système de
suspension et pour lequel ils avaient
deux qui étaient couronné qu'elle avait
à peine 25 ans en 1953 disait ce fut la
balade la plus épouvantable dans la vie
de ma vie vous savez quoi on a on a les
images du couronnement de la reine
regarde on va regarder le vous adorer ça
je vous offre ça je sais pas si les
images sont très chers mais je vous
l'offre
au moment où sous les yeux de ces deux
enfants la reine Elizabeth dans toute sa
majesté sort du palais de Buckingham 10
millions de citoyens britanniques et un
demi million de visiteurs étrangers
s'apprêtent à lui faire un triomphe
comme on en vit jamais
et d'apprendre tu nous as dit que le
faire-part c'était le côté bio la
verdure la nature voilà voilà c'est
aujourd'hui c'est comme ça on fait
attention à la planète pourquoi on prend
pas même s'il aura excuse-moi du terme
un peu mal au cul dans ce truc à cheval
plutôt que de polluer dans la
Rolls-Royce ou là je sais pas quoi
parce que c'est ça correspond pas
à ce qu'il faut le faire par la verdure
tu sais et là il se dit je vais avoir
mal au ventre
beaucoup de pollution et le carrosse
sera quand même utilisé pour le retour
donc de la baignade on est certain qu'il
utilise ce carrosse
de grands problèmes de dons rappelle que
pendant toute la cérémonie donc c'est
deux heures et non pas 3h30 pour
Elisabeth II ça a été ramené à 2h il va
être assis sur ce fameux trône de
sainte-édouard et ça c'est un calvaire
aussi c'est un trône qui a plus de 1000
ans qui est entièrement en plus
on nous dit qu'il s'entraîne il
s'entraîne parce que la couronne de
fatigue
c'est presque deux kilos en 1600 grammes
une fois quand même devoir donc il a la
couronne de Monsieur
il a la couronne sur la tête
franchement et ça j'aime bien et ça en
soirée tu fais un malheur
avec ça c'est vraiment c'était mauvais
hein
mais regardez il y a le sceptre qui
tient dans sa main droite il y a l'orbe
qu'il tient dans sa vie
et tout cela une symbolique complètement
incroyable il a des éperons qu'il va
devoir chausser je vous assure que
physiquement
non plus moi peut-être je reconnais que
lorsqu'on a 74 ans que les caméras du
monde entier sont braqués sur toi que
tous les droits à l'image ont été
revendus mais Benjamin donc dire ça ça
va vous intéresser Benjamin la cérémonie
coûte 100 millions de livres stériliques
ah ah donc 114 millions d'euros et de là
c'est intégralement déjà remboursé par
les droits télévisuels l'Angleterre va
très mal et que les anglais sont dans
une crise au moins ça fera pas polémique
exactement encore qu'on a un préfet qui
dépense 50 millions qui gardent 50
millions pour le peuple mais bon ça oui
je dis rien quels sont les stars qui
seront présentes et quelles stars ont
été invités alors pour la journée du
couronnement qui a lieu le samedi il y a
pas vraiment y avoir de stars donc
Elisabeth de 8000 invités ici il a
ramené la chose à 2000 pourquoi parce
que pour asseoir 8000 invités à l'époque
en 1953 il avait fallu installer de la
tribune et tout ça avait pris du temps
avait demandé de l'argent donc on a
supprimé il y aura plus de 2000 comme on
est limité à 2000 invités on invite
vraiment que les indispensables alors
effectivement beaucoup de chefs d'État
et de souverain alors que c'était pas du
tout le cas avant il veut donner un côté
un peu soft power oh que tu es un peu
dynamique à cette cérémonie et on estime
que par exemple l'empare et la
directrice du Japon qui vont finir le
sultan de Brunei qui est attendu
Emmanuel et Brigitte Macron qui seront
la partie Albert et Charlène de Monaco
vont permettre un peu de spectacle pour
les caméras du monde entier les autres
ce sont des notables des diplomates
d'anciens premiers ministres voilà ça a
un côté quand même très je crois qu'il
devait venir des chanteurs très connus
il y a
attends
pour moi
on t'appellera pas pour l'agitateur
parce que je te rassure mais en revanche
il y a pas une petite fête un peu un peu
le lendemain Benjamin le jour du matin
le lendemain c'est grand concert au
château de Winsor ou là en effet à Kia
est attendu Brian
mais par exemple
pour pour un Pépito et un coca il vient
maintenant je me dis
ça
je vois que vous voulez en venir une
panique il y avait de nombreuses stars
elle est tout ça voilà en effet de se
mêler pas que des conneries
en Allemagne
en fait il veut pas du tout aller
couronné de
très très important l'Ordre de la
Couronne britannique en Angleterre
d'Emma de Charlotte elle nous dit
qu'elle devient pas alors qu'elle pour
le coup d'exercice
le jour de la cérémonie non moi en
revanche je serai à l'autre le vendredi
le jour de de la répétition générale
voilà
quelques surprises lors du couronnement
1000 autres ils ont reconstitué l'abbaye
de Westminster dans la salle de Bâle de
Buckingham Palace où les répétitions ont
déjà lieu pour l'instant tellement tout
va être chronométré il est assis pendant
deux heures mais non il faut il va pas
être assis pendant deux heures non non
quand je vous dis que c'est festival à
faire des trucs
du pouvoir il doit prononcer un discours
alors William à un moment donné va venir
s'agenouiller devant lui pour lui
promettre fidélité puisqu'il devient le
premier de ses serviteurs voilà
de Weber le grand compositeur
fantôme
pour réaliser 10 musiques spéciales
c'est une bande son qui est vraiment
étudiée et qui va se terminer par le
Zadok
vous savez ce grand air de couronnement
ou pendant 4 minutes on va venir lui
apposer la couronne de droite sur la
tête alors qu'est-ce que ça va changer
son son couronnement rien du tout
techniquement
[Applaudissements]
c'est la c'est une vous savez c'est une
cérémonie qu'il fait mon estime que Dieu
descend sur Terre durant quelques
minutes pour le couronné lui c'est la
dernière dynastie qui fait qui fait ce
genre de choses voilà 100 millions vous
le dites pour cela mais alors c'est
surtout la sécurité Benjamin on estime
que la moitié de ce budget là est
affrêté à la sécurité pourquoi parce que
je vous rappelle on sort on sort tous
les joyaux de la Tour de Londres il pour
l'instant sont chez mapping and wehbeen
qui est l'ancêtre officiel du palais et
les couronnes sont en train d'être
redimensionnés à la taille du ça on va
au revoir des bijoux de famille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
se passe très vite mais ça fait des
années des années et des années qu'elle
est dans le dans le sens
pourquoi pourquoi
il est allé épouser Diana alors qu'en
fait il fait l'autre et Obélix aux
ordres du palais c'est pour elle qui lui
a dit Kamila c'est pas possible elle est
rose donc j'étais pas dans leur ioté
celle-là celle-là je me serais dans un
bordel
justement là ça c'est vraiment la
question qui est sur toutes les lèvres
pour l'instant les équipes du palais
nous disent nous on fait comme si ils
étaient là parce que nous n'avons pas
reçu pour l'instant d'indication
contraire toujours est-il que je vous
disais que les cartons d'invitation
officielle ne sont pas encore là c'est
donc ils n'ont pas encore été tenus
officiellement de répondre on estime que
les cartons vont partir en début de
semaine prochaine là il devrait y avoir
une réponse
alors juste le carton arrive par la
poste ou il arrive par la poste pas bien
2000 cartons moi je pensais qu'il y a un
mec qui est arrivé oh yeah
[Rires]
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est quand même pas tout non
on a
qui a été donné par les équipes du
palais à ce carton d'invitation c'est
élisabelle stephys TV
pourquoi alors soit c'est pour le papier
parce que le papier raide ou alors on
dit que c'est ceux qui attendent le
carton on attend avec tellement
d'excitation merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]